the second round of Democratic
presidential debates begins tonight and
a new poll shows Joe Biden surging far
ahead of the others in his this 2020
race 34 percent of likely Democratic
voters in the poll say they support the
former vice president Warren and Sanders
lead tonight's pack of candidates and
all are trying to make their mark at
this crucial time in the race ed O'Keefe
is at the debate site in Detroit Edie
how's the contest shaping up well good
morning Tony could be a big turning
point in the friendship of Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren two
like-minded liberals who we know spend
some time together in Washington when
they're there it also could be a big
night for the lesser-known more moderate
Democrats on stage who are eager to
break through we want to make change in
this country it's got to be big
structural change on our way to Detroit
last night Elizabeth Warren stopped in
Toledo Ohio to tap her economic plan per
rally came a day after Bernie Sanders
traveled to Canada to make the case for
his medicare-for-all a proposal we are
going to take on the greed and the
corruption of the pharmaceutical
industry the two liberals are hoping to
take a bite out of former Vice President
Joe Biden's lead Biden who takes the
stage tomorrow night has vowed to turn
up the heat after facing criticism for
his record on race do you agree today
that you were wrong to oppose busing in
America though do you agree I did not
oppose busing in America last week Biden
said he won't hesitate to defend his
political history
I was probably overly polite and the way
I didn't respond and in Detroit
yesterday senator Kamala Harris was
asked about Biden's vow not to be polite
at Wednesday's debate my mother raised
me to be polite and I intend to be
polite Democrats are debating in
Michigan with the hope of winning it
back from president Trump who won here
in 2016
by fewer than 11,000 votes but voters
here tell us they want candidates to
focus on the issues something that's not
just I'm not Donald Trump I want to know
about what their plans are for reducing
student debt there are things like the
environment to meet health care because
it's through the roof this is just the
second time we've seen all these
candidates on stage together and
we can't emphasize this enough a huge
night for those lesser-known names who
are hoping to make it to the third
debate in September Anthony thank you
very much